[Music]
the league of legends show was good even
the sonic movies were decent now as a
new era dawns for video game adaptations
a series will remind us don't get too
excited they're still usually ass
[Music]
halo
microsoft tried for decades to bring
halo to hollywood but after bailing on
movies from great directors bailing on
shows from the best producers and
bailing on showrunners who even looked
at the game they'll bail on even trying
to adapt the game's storyline for the
studio that bailed on terminator the
turtles and transformers on mtv and
avatar man paramount is just dangling
from tom cruise's giant nods
follow along on the master chief's
evolution from a no-nonsense soldier who
never takes his helmet off to a
helmetless rebel who disobeys orders and
turns on his creator which is fine if
the show built up to all that but since
it happens in episode 1 there's nothing
left to do for the other eight hours
except
[Music]
to be fair you can't write a whole
series about an honorable space warrior
whose face you never see
uh twice
you couldn't do that twice but she's not
alone meet a team slayer's worth of
characters like quan a girl with a
backstory as tragic as her haircut
soarin who runs a libertarian hideout
functional enough to make churros any
good churros today yes it's hot all
right give me half a duck now that's
sci-fi dr halsey a character based on
the showrunner and that she doesn't care
what people think about her work and
she's ruined a bunch of childhoods
miranda keys a strong woman of color who
won't be denied her place as the usmc's
next joseph mengele other spartans like
kai 125 who follow chief's lead by
literally pulling the emotions out of
her butt
mckee the most consistently shocked
character in tv history
she died as she lived being surprised
and cortana the ai personal assistant
that's a bit like having clippy drilled
into your skull against your will
but hey at least they got the original
voice actors to play here any halo fans
stick around till episode three no you
went back to playing halo huh well i
didn't have that option
since 2001 gamers have been dreaming of
what halo would look like in live action
that day has finally come but it looks
like 2001 is when they stopped improving
the graphics with just three goofy
looking battle scenes spread across nine
hours and nothing for halo's core fans
to enjoy in between except that move
where you swap guns with a marine the
world's shortest warthog ride
[Applause]
and that thing where the story only
moves forward when chief touches a big
alien mcguffin
[Music]
you know to be fair it's not just a
mcguffin it's also the deus ex machina
for ending any scene
[Applause]
we really could have used this when
cortana was watching master chief have
do you think he's tea bagging
fear the covenant a horrifying glimpse
of what would happen if the star wars
trade federation found religion who live
inside a big floating mushroom tip and
have a generic evil plan to activate the
mysterious halo but since they spend the
whole season looking for the halo we
only get a tiny glimpse of the halo and
even then they're pretty vague about why
they want a halo meaning if you wanted a
show set on halo you can probably just
start with season 2 of halo now with
bits of actual halo halo is an
adaptation that takes great licence with
the source material parameter three four
three industries not promised halo
appear in hello season two used to
demand to see a deadly hidden ring are
encouraged to look at their own
buttholes
so enjoy a return to the battle days of
video game adaptation where instead of
pleasing the game's fans and relying on
them to tell the normies how good it is
they'll take gamers for granted and try
to appeal to a broad audience of nfl
dads and their teenage sons because halo
is one of those niche things that only
the most hopeless nerds could care about
right it's only so let's see here 80
million copies
this i'm gonna rewatch red versus blue
instead what is that
what thing there's something on your
head what is it a spider get it off it's
like a blue thing like a blue spider
starring
master bait blues clues
cerebral halsey
mckees nuts
fem chef she comes from the planet
madrigal i used to be a spartan like you
then i took a griddle to the arm
burn gorman once again his real name is
burn gorman
and starry krishnas
board of the ring
[Music]
all right i forgot quan is actually part
of an ancient bloodline destined to
protect a mysterious portal hidden by a
white dreadlock tribe at the bottom of a
well it doesn't matter on the show but
well now you know and knowing is half
the run time
hey screen junkies our benevolent
overlords at fandom have a twitch
channel now click the box on the right
to check it out and subscribe for
playthroughs with the honest game
trailer crew and coming this summer
movie and tv watch logs for upcoming
honest trailers cool
i need a weapon
do you ever wonder why we're here